[MUSIC PLAYING]
CHALMERS BROWNE: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
I'm Chalmers Browne.
For those of you
who don't know me,
I'm a business systems analyst
in our Corporate Engineering
area.
I now work on our
[INAUDIBLE] cloud project,
but for most of my five
plus years here at Google,
I've been working alongside
our People Operations team
building out systems like
GHire, Perf, and Grow.
Today's event is called
"Hustle x Heart--
The Silver Lining
of Work Culture."
And we are honored to be joined
by Claude Silver, VaynerMedia's
inaugural--
[APPLAUSE]
--VaynerMedia's
inaugural Chief Heart
officer, a first of its
kind position created
to scale the company's
people first ethos.
Claude champions
empathy-driven leadership
as she overseas talent
management, employee
experience, and recruitment
for over 750 employees
at VaynerMedia, which is
a Gary Vaynerchuk company.
For those of you who
might not be familiar,
Gary Vaynerchuk is a
serial entrepreneur
and the CEO and
co-founder of VaynerMedia,
which is a full service digital
agency serving Fortune 500
clients across the
company's four locations.
And Gary is also the host of a
widely successful "Ask Gary V"
show on YouTube.
CLAUDE SILVER: I think he
has a really popular channel
on YouTube.
CHALMERS BROWNE: Yeah.
CLAUDE SILVER: I
think it's now GaryV.
CHALMERS BROWNE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Claude's current
role is the capstone
of a career that spans nearly
20 years at numerous Fortune 50
companies, including
senior leadership
posts at J Walter Thompson
and Publicist in London.
Her success in guiding
employee experience,
client relationships, global
brand strategies, operations,
and management is
driven by an abiding
passion for creating spaces
in which people can thrive.
Please join me in
welcoming Claude Silver.
CLAUDE SILVER: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
Thanks.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
Good to be here.
Really good to be here.
CHALMERS BROWNE: Thank
you for being here.
Quick housekeeping--
please silence all devices.
And we will have some
time for Q&A at the end.
Since we're recording,
it's very important
that if you have a question,
please ask it at one
of the two mics in the aisles.
So for people in the
audience, who might not
be familiar with
VaynerMedia, what
would you say is the
company's mission,
and how is that different
from other companies
in your industry or other
companies in general?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah,
so we're a full--
VaynerMedia is a full
service digital agency.
So we're really a
creative shop that
marries both paid media,
creative, and strategy
in the middle, not unlike
a lot of other agencies
that you probably
work with for sure.
And Gary would say our mission
is to build the biggest
human empire of all time.
I'd like to be a part
of that for sure.
But I think the differentiator
for us is that we really
do put people at the
center, that because we
are an independently
owned agency,
of course, we want to make sure
that we're paying attention
to our top and bottom
line and the growth there.
But it is really the people
that fuel all of that,
and I really--
I personally think
that the emphasis
that we put on
people, the emphasis
that we put on a
culture, the emphasis
that we even have a
job like mine, which
is very different than a chief
HR officer, which we'll get to,
I'm sure--
that in itself sets us apart.
I don't think it makes us
better or holier than thou.
I think it just makes
us very different,
and it is something that
is hard to grok sometimes
that, yeah, OK, well,
are you just like Droga5?
Are you like Anomaly?
We're different.
We really beat to
a different drum,
and I think a lot of
that is because of who
Gary Vaynerchuk is-- an
incredibly fast-moving empath
that is known for hustle.
But quite frankly, he's got
a heck of a lot of heart.
CHALMERS BROWNE: So the
term, "honey empire,"
comes up frequently in reference
to Vayner and your role.
Can you explain what that means?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah, I can.
There's a lot of
different breakdowns,
but I've definitely honed
my verbatim, I think,
at this point.
There's two different
ways I look at it.
So being people first,
that's obviously the honey.
That is taking
care of the people.
That is making sure that if
someone is having a bad day,
we're taking care of them.
If someone got
engaged or married,
we're celebrating that.
It is really the idea of
creating champions from one
another, the collaboration, the
emphasis on working together
to create the biggest
honey empire of all time.
The empire, of course, is
much more of a success.
It's much more of the client
success, the personal success,
the agency shop success.
So that is one
way to look at it.
The other way I like to look
at it is something-- actually,
I am going to use
this little easel.
Do you mind?
CHALMERS BROWNE: Yeah, go ahead.
Please.
CLAUDE SILVER: Hopefully,
I'm writing big enough
for the camera.
But fundamentally,
if I think about how
I look at building strong
teams and building teams that
are sustainable and
they last, I look
at starting with the connection.
Again, hopefully,
that can be read.
So connection-- as
human beings, we
are absolutely wired to belong.
We are wired to connect
with one another.
Connection plus trust-- so
once I connect with you,
and I'm kind of
like in it with you,
we start to trust one another.
I might let my guard
down a little bit more.
I might be a little
bit easier with you.
I might share something
about myself with you.
Plus, empathy-- so I trust now,
but now I'm sharing something.
Maybe I'm sharing about an issue
I'm having on another team,
or maybe I'm sharing something
about something, a family
issue or a celebration
or something like that.
Connection plus trust
plus empathy, honey,
equals accountability,
which also
is another way to say loyalty.
Longevity-- so we want
our people to be there
with us for the long haul.
We want Vayner people to be
with us forever, quite frankly.
Gary will say that.
I want you to work
with me forever.
Accountability,
longevity, resilience--
who doesn't need
resilience in these times?
I mean, things are changing.
I'm sure you already launched
three different products,
while I've been sitting
here with you today.
But the world of digital is
changing every single second,
so you need to be able to
roll with those punches.
And also, Gary is a disruptor.
He's an entrepreneur.
I mean, it is--
he can say today, by
the time we get back,
we're not going to do that.
We're going to do this.
And we all have to
pivot very quickly.
So resilience is really
important in our teams
and our people.
Accountability, longevity,
resilience equals speed.
This is the empire right here.
Speed is our number one KPI.
People first-- here
are the feelings.
Here are all the things that
I care about all day long.
And here's the
empire, the fact of,
how do we get it
across the finish line?
So I hope that
answered the question
in a very esoteric way.
CHALMERS BROWNE: Yeah, that's
Great So you mentioned--
I think you probably get
this question all the time.
How is your role as
Chief Heart officer
different from a traditional
chief HR officer role?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah, I
mean I'm not HR at all.
I've never been HR.
In fact, I started in '98
before Google, before Facebook,
as a project manager
in San Francisco,
and then morphed my
way into the agency
side on the client-facing
side, and then
found my home in strategy.
And way, way, way back
when, I was training
to be a psychotherapist.
So human development,
human behavior is always
something that's really,
really fascinated me
and still does to this day.
That's kind of like
everything for me--
how we work, why we work,
how we can work better.
And so I've been a strategist
for a very long time, almost
20 years.
And I am not HR.
I'm not-- I'm certainly
now HR, and I'm
more equipped and more
educated in the science of HR
and the benefits and
international visas and laws
and whatnot.
But that's not my job.
We have some incredible HR
people in the crowd right
now that are on my
team, which is amazing.
And they really take care of the
HR factor, the science of it,
the benefits, payroll, 401(k)s,
and really, the reviews,
the review cycle, all
of those things as well.
So my job isn't.
I mean, you would say,
send that to Claude,
because she's head
of HR, but I'm not.
I get to oversee
that which is, and I
get to co-create with
people that know more
than I know in terms of HR.
And Gary really
sees himself as HR,
because he's a
people first person.
And so the synergy
that he and I have
in terms of how we feel about
people, our belief in people,
our gut about people is
really what created this role
and why we call it Heart,
because we actually
think of HR, which I have no
idea what that really means,
as heart.
In fact, we changed the
name of the department
when I started to
People and Experience,
because after all, that's
what we're doing here.
You have a department,
People Ops.
It's very similar.
CHALMERS BROWNE:
Yep very similar.
CLAUDE SILVER: But the idea
of human resources, to me,
is very foreign.
I really-- I don't
get it, but if anyone
wants to explain those
two terms to me, I'm open.
So people and experience, and
really, I'm not chief of HR.
But again, we've got a great
team that takes care of that.
CHALMERS BROWNE: Excellent.
So one of the things
you've called yourself
is an emphatic
truth-teller, when
you were describing what it
was that Gary needed to sort
of scale what he did
for the organization
as the organization expanded.
What's the hardest truth
you've had to tell,
or at least the hardest
one you can share with us?
CLAUDE SILVER: Sure.
It's empathic.
Empathic.
I think someone once called
me an empathic truth-teller.
CHALMERS BROWNE: Oh, OK.
Maybe I misheard that.
CLAUDE SILVER:
Maybe it's emphatic.
I'm sure.
Hopefully, it's enthusiastic,
but you know, it's hard.
It is a challenge,
I think, sometimes
to confront someone with
something they may not
see about themselves.
It's hard as another
human being to take
that step, that bold
step forward as just
another learner in the world and
to think that I see something
that they don't see.
By no means, am I-- you know,
I'm not a psychotherapist.
I'm not a physician.
So it's really difficult
to get up the gumption
and want to shine a mirror
in front of someone.
And I think that's a difficult
thing that we all have.
However, when we give feedback,
and when we share something
with another person, it's
really an act of caring.
So when I don't do that,
I'm really withholding--
quite frankly, I'm
manipulating someone's growth
and development.
And the way I go about it is,
hopefully, with as much grace,
tact, and generosity of
spirit as I possibly can.
But that is something
that I think is--
you just have to step wisely
into those shoes, cautiously,
of course, because
you never know
how someone's going to react.
But if you go into
that truth, again,
with empathy and with
humility-- my god--
then I think the door can
open to so much possibility.
And that's what it's all about--
possibility.
CHALMERS BROWNE:
Is there an example
that you can think of,
where telling that truth--
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah,
there's an example.
I mean, when did I get here?
So I think an hour
ago, I was in a room
with a very senior
account holder, account--
our client service person.
And this person was telling
me that he has been exploring
his team for the
last three months,
and these are the
three buckets that he
thinks are wrong with his team.
So he's probably my age.
He's in his 40s, and maybe
he knows more about life
than I do.
I have no idea.
But he and I have had many
conversations over the past,
I would say, eight
or nine months
about these issues in his
team, and only today, he's
bringing them to me.
So what I did say to him
is, with all due respect,
I really believe that
you've been protecting
your team this entire time.
There's no need to
protect your team,
and these three
buckets that you just
shared with us should have been
shared with me nine months ago,
because we could have fixed it.
We didn't need to go through
all the rigmarole and all
the people issues and all the
hardship and all the missed
deadlines and all
of those things,
if we just could get truth.
So that's probably the
most recent conversation,
and he took it as
well as can be.
We'll see what happens
when I get back to work.
But again, you go into
it with as much grace
and just generosity.
I want to help him.
CHALMERS BROWNE:
So your role was
created to help preserve
Vayner's culture,
while it grows rapidly.
We know a little bit
about that here at Google.
What are the elements
of Vayner's culture
that you most fear losing as you
continue to expand and scale?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah,
so yeah, this role
was created to scale Gary.
And he says to scale the
unscalable, which I think
is a phenomenal way to say it.
I mean, how do we scale culture?
That's the big question.
It's a question I get all
the time and a question
I'm sure you guys get at almost
80,000 people and wanting
to maintain Google
across the world.
So our culture is really built
on a few different values
that I can say, over the
last eight and 1/2 years,
are pretty tried and true.
Empathy, which I will
call heart, speed,
which I would call hustle,
hustle and heart, possibility--
we work for an entrepreneur, and
everything really is possible.
There is a yes all the
time, until there isn't.
But it takes a very long time
to get to the no, if ever.
Positivity-- I mean Gary
overindexes as an optimist.
I'm probably very
close behind him.
And winning,
competitiveness-- and those
are things I believe
are still in our DNA,
absolutely, over
eight and 1/2 years.
But those are things
that we need to continue
to stoke the fire on.
So for example, let's take the
conversation that I just had.
That conversation
was out of line
and out of touch
with our culture,
because the winning
was misguided.
The wanting to win
was cased in fear.
That's not one of our values.
It's not how we use
and foster our culture.
And that's just talking
to one individual.
Where is that-- is
that spread anywhere?
I mean, so the most
important thing
that I'm doing
every single day is
I'm talking to a lot of people.
Quite frankly, I'm listening
to a lot of people,
and I'm just collecting
data, collecting information,
I'm holding space to see what
happens, to see what comes out.
And as I'm speaking to
people and collecting data,
I'm looking for patterns.
And I'm looking to hear if
I hear a similarity on one
certain team or if I hear a
similarity on a department,
even though the department
might be in a different country.
It might have legs in
a different culture--
different company--
sorry, different country.
And so as I hear
these patterns, that's
where we start to deploy
more people that are what I
like to call culture carriers.
By no means is their
title culture carrier,
although they should put
it in their signature.
These are people that really
get a sense of the water
that we're drinking
every single day.
It's not Kool-Aid.
It's water.
It's pure.
It's real.
And so in every office, and
certainly in our offices here
in New York, which
we have two, I
can depend on and rely
on using and asking
that person or that
person or that person
to go take that person for a
walk or for a cup of coffee,
or go have a little mini town
hall with those eight people,
who are just kind of crusty.
So that is something that is--
it's like a 24/7 job.
It's an absolute 24/7 job, which
meeting with people one on one,
having hangouts with
people, going to--
I'll start a big
round of office visits
next week in different
countries and different cities.
And so making sure that
we have that high touch
at every single moment.
Obviously, Gary is doing
the same exact thing.
He might be doing
five-minute meetings.
a lot of texting,
but we try to cover as much
ground as we possibly can,
and ensuring that the
culture is still being fed
and watered so that we can have
new sprouts every single day.
I talk in metaphors
a lot, but that's
what it looks like
to me, quite frankly.
It's 800 people now--
what?
I think 805 people, I
think, and that's a lot.
That's just a lot of heartbeats.
It's a lot of mouths to
feed, and certainly don't
need to explain that to Google.
So we've got we've got
a lot of learning to do,
but I do think that we've
implemented some really good
tried and tested abilities now.
CHALMERS BROWNE: In
the run-up to 800,
are there things that
you feel like you sort
of lost irretrievably
or things that
just couldn't survive from the
smaller scale to the larger
scale?
CLAUDE SILVER: I don't
think we lost them.
I think we lost sight of
them, and then got them back.
That's what I think.
So in terms of growing,
growing, growing,
that's just-- for example,
the talent team that's here.
I mean, there was
a period of time,
and there's only
about five of them
in all different countries.
In New York, we've got
three, three or four.
But there was a time that they
were hiring hand over fist.
I mean we couldn't bring
enough bodies into the offices
and into our world.
And what we lost
sight of was training,
and what we lost sight
of was the orientation.
And what we ended up doing
is throwing them into a fire
without giving them
a sense of what's
in our DNA, what's in our
bloodstream and our water.
And there were moments, I would
say, in the last 18 months,
two years that you
could feel the ground
start to not tremble, but just
start to shake a little bit,
or the wheels on the bus just
start to rattle a little bit,
a little harder than I like.
I like a lot of speed,
but it was a little much.
And in those moments,
that's something
that I talked to Gary about, I'm
going to talk to my team about,
and we have to kind of do a
full court press in that moment.
There's some things
that we're not
going to be able to retrofit
and change, but going forward,
we know how important
it is to orient.
We have a week-long
orientation--
and how important it is for
that employee to really,
really connect to get a sense
of belonging, tried and true.
We want them here.
We've gone through three rounds
of interviewing, maybe four.
And so when they
come in, we already
have this incredible
sense of belief in them,
and it takes an
employee, obviously,
a longer time to
believe in the org.
But in those cases, where
we got lost a little bit.
And so anyway,
we've retrofitted.
CHALMERS BROWNE:
And are there things
that you find that you can
do at scale that you couldn't
do when you were smaller?
CLAUDE SILVER: That,
I actually believe
in terms of going back
in time a little bit.
Back in time's not the
right way to say it,
because we can't
go back in time.
But we can certainly go back
and have that conversation
with that swath of people
that we may have missed.
We moved to-- we opened up
our first international office
about 15 months ago in
London, and in doing so,
we sent out ex-pats
to open up the office.
One of the things we
learned very quickly is--
and I worked in London for a
significant amount of time.
So it's something I
knew, but as an ex-pat,
it's different with
different glasses on.
It's so important to get
locals in your office
and get locals in
your office fast.
Otherwise, it really is like the
American invasion in many ways,
and that's not going to work.
That's not going to
work in another country,
but it's certainly not going
to work when you are a local,
and you walk in, and
there's eight ex-pats,
and they're telling
you what to do.
So those are things that we've
had to look at and reverse
engineer as we go forward.
CHALMERS BROWNE: So
we're just finishing up
our performance management
and compensation cycle.
Every company has them
in some form or another.
But those processes--
performance management,
compensation planning--
they're often seen as sort
of being directly at odds
with the effort to create
psychological safety, a culture
of trust.
How do you handle performance
evaluation and rewards
without undermining
the honey empire?
CLAUDE SILVER: It's so tough.
I mean this crew in front
of me that's on my team--
they're the ones that take a
little bit of the bruising,
because there is such a
juxtaposition between we
love you.
We believe in you, We want you.
You have a home.
We want you here forever.
Here's 6%.
Or you just got all fives on
a review, on a review form,
because we just got out
of our cycle as well.
But you're not getting
promoted, but here's 10%.
These are really
hard conversations.
I don't have the answer,
other than so much high touch.
And that means spending
time with that employee,
going back to that
employee, letting
them know we work for them,
working with their manager,
seeing how we can--
if we're not able to give
them the salary increase
that they were so hoping
for, and it is 6%,
or it is 8%, making sure that
what's in their review in terms
of their training and
development or their growth
plans, we are hitting
immediately or as soon
as we possibly can.
That's one way I think
that we can surround
that person or that
cohort with as much heart,
as much honey as
we possibly can.
Spending time with Gary is
always going to be a benefit,
and it's weird to kind of
dangle that in front sometimes.
But it is so
incredibly helpful when
you get that time with Gary, and
he's able to, in his own words,
really, really hone
you into the vision,
because the vision is--
the vision's amazing.
The vision of what
we're doing, we're
building an agency so that
at some point in time,
we can buy brands and own
them and create the marketing
and awareness for them--
that's awesome.
There's not a lot of
agencies that are doing that.
But it is something we need
to spend a lot of time with
and a lot of not coddling and
not pampering, but just, again,
high touch.
I say that phrase a
lot, but it is really
what we do, from a
resident on up to an SVP.
CHALMERS BROWNE: And sort of in
line with that, as Chief Heart
officer, how do you go about
helping someone when they're
not succeeding in their role?
CLAUDE SILVER: So when they're
not succeeding in their role,
we do as much of
a 360 as we can,
first and foremost, to find
out, is that really true?
Or is that just that one
person or that one manager from
the top down that's like,
blah-blah-blah-blah,
because that's not fair.
So we really try to look
at it in a holistic manner
and get as much 360
as we possibly can.
We put people on
performance plans--
30-day, 60-day,
sometimes 90-day.
In London, we will extend
that notice period--
we will extend that
90-day trial period,
if we need to, for
another three months.
We want people to be successful.
Again, we've invested
so much time,
as you do, too, in recruiting,
finding that right talent,
bringing them in, orienting.
I, mean it costs a
lot of money, also.
Talk about the empire.
You know, it's-- so when
you lose an employee,
it costs almost double, triple
to get that next employee in.
So making sure that we're
giving them very specific,
clear ways in which to
improve is-- that's our job--
actionable, measurable
ways to improve.
Otherwise, that's not fair.
So we spend a lot
of time doing that.
We don't have a lot of
people on performance plans.
I don't know if that's
a good or a bad thing.
Maybe we're not looking deep
enough, but for the most part,
I think coming out of this
review cycle right now,
I can say that it's a
very low percentage,
and we're doing our best to get
people to get the Cs up to a B,
and to get the Bs up to an A.
One of the things that we do
have that I'm super proud of
is we have this alumni program.
So if someone-- if we
have a C that we know
will be an A somewhere
else, or if we
have someone that it's
just not working out,
we're just not the right
culture, for example,
or we just move too fast,
we will do our very best,
as we let them go, to
find their next interview,
to find their next role.
And so we can do that based
on Gary's network, of course,
and based on the enormous
amount of job requests
he's getting in every single
day, like, hey, do you
have a-- hey, do you have a?
And so we'll do our best
to do the networking,
and then set them up with
that first interview.
CHALMERS BROWNE: So
one of the things
that I think we've
noted in our culture
and that we're struggling with
is, how do you make a manager?
How do you take somebody
who's a tremendous performer
as an individual contributor,
and either determine
that they should or
shouldn't be a manager,
and then make sure they have
the manager skill sets, which
are actually, generally,
very different
from the skill
sets that made them
successful as an
individual contributor?
What's your approach
to making managers?
CLAUDE SILVER: So we
are in the process
of figuring out that training.
I'll tell you--
I should say, not
unsimilar to many agencies,
you get promoted, and you
just rise through a ladder,
and you just get
maybe, like, a higher
salary and more responsibility.
But there isn't a lot of
manager training in agencies,
probably due to the
nature of our work,
that it's incredibly fast.
We're in the service of clients.
We have an output.
Thank you very much,
so forth, and so on,
and you keep on going
on and on and on.
Management training is something
we kicked off in January
in different forms, and that
included our presentation
training.
That included Radical
Candor feedback training.
That is now including
facilitation training,
but we are still figuring
out, what is the right--
what is a VaynerMedia manager,
recognizing that we want
everyone to have uniqueness?
And how do we go about
having that training?
How do we go about,
is it one on one?
I mean, obviously,
experiential is the way to do--
I believe that we learn
faster when we experience it.
We either teach it,
or we experience it.
So we're developing
those things right now.
And I absolutely wish
I had a magic wand,
and we could make
that happen faster.
But spending time with people
and really figuring out
what makes them beat,
what makes them tick,
kind of helping
them figure out kind
of their own human
behavior so that they
can be that much more
tuned in to others I think
is the key there.
CHALMERS BROWNE: All right.
I have a couple more questions,
but I want to take a minute
and just see if there are
questions in the audience
that--
yeah.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
CLAUDE SILVER: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Something that is so
important, yet hard to manage
for a lot of people that
I know that you've done,
having worked with you
before really well,
is one, found your passion,
and then, secondly,
found a way to get there.
I would just love-- and I know
you mentor a lot of people
in that way, too.
I'd love to hear
your perspective
on that, tips and tricks
of how you kind of found
this and navigated
your way [INAUDIBLE]..
CLAUDE SILVER: Thanks, Carrie.
Carrie and I have worked
with each other about 13
or 15 years ago, so thanks
for being the first question.
So I love doing coaching,
and I love mentoring.
And throughout my
years, whether or not I
was at this company
or that agency
or running my own
surfing company,
I've picked up a lot of positive
psychology tips and tricks
along the way and life coaching
and executive coaching tools.
And I do a lot of coaching.
I call them white
board sessions.
Some people might call
them north star sessions.
But what I find is most
important with all people
and all human beings
is making sure
that, at some point
in our existence,
we were able to define
and touch our purpose.
Our passion and our purpose
could be very different.
One of my passions
is snowboarding,
but my purpose has nothing
to do with snowboarding.
So there's a difference there.
So I take people through
values exercises.
I really like people
to be big in the room.
That's something I say a
lot, so when they're with me,
and they're in one of these
45-minute, hour long sessions,
what I say to them is, like,
it's just us in the room,
so be big.
Like, tell me, really, what is
the value you bring to teams?
No one's listening--
just you and me.
Then I'll look at their values.
Sometimes I even ask
them what they wanted
to be when they were kids.
What did they want to
be when they grew up?
Because I think when we go
back to the origin of time,
and we were just
innocent, and we wanted
to be an astronaut or a
film director or whatnot,
there's a lot of truth in that.
And sometimes there's
still threads.
There's still like
a red thread that
runs through from when you were
a kid to when you're an adult.
I really ask people to--
it's a funny, little
corny question,
but to think about, in their
most innocent of times,
brushing their teeth
in the morning.
Just who are they?
Where's their resonance?
Are they mad?
Are they-- like, when you wake
up in the morning, who are you?
What type of person are you?
And then I sew all
of that together,
and hopefully, we land on a
guiding principle or a mission
statement, something that
they are really proud of,
and they can own.
And they put-- like I say,
put that in your wallet,
or put that on your laptop,
because it's unique to each
and every individual.
And I really think that
once, if we're successful--
and this might take three
sessions with them--
they go back to their
desk, and they can use
some of that with other people.
I mean that's how I'm scaling
myself, quite frankly.
Aside from the
team, if I'm having
this incredible interaction
with another human being,
that they're going
back to their desk,
their team, their
cohort, and they're
able to sprinkle
their own magic dust.
And that way, the good
vibes just keep on going.
But that's what I do.
I just spend a lot of time
doing a lot of coaching
and just creating
space for people
to just be whomever they want.
At VaynerMedia-- and I wouldn't
doubt at Google as well-- we're
teaching a lot more than just
fundamental skills of how
to use Ad Manager or how to be
an incredible client service
person, I mean as life skills.
So yes, you can teach empathy.
Someone has to be interested
and open to learning.
You can teach self-awareness
and those types of things.
So I think that's what
juices me every single day,
that I don't have to just--
I'm not just talking
about how to get
this bottle into more hands.
I'm talking about,
why would you even
be interested in getting
this bottle into more hands?
CHALMERS BROWNE: We
have another question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for being here.
I had an opportunity to see Gary
speak the first time like two
weeks ago at a
conference, and as you all
know, who probably work for him,
he has the energy and ability
to kind of mic drop
on the whole room
and make people kind of
silence after, be like,
I want to be part
of what he's doing.
Or it's so just engaging.
So my question is kind of
on the recruiting process.
Do you guys find that a
lot of your applicants
come from Gary V lovers, who
just are a huge fan of him
and want to work for
him, or maybe even
some of the recruiters in
the room who work at Vayner?
Like, what is your
guys' process?
Do you reach out?
Do you have a bunch of
people like that, who apply?
I can only imagine,
after hearing him speak.
So just wanted to know kind
of what the recruiting process
looks like.
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah, cool.
Keep me honest, team.
But he's absolutely
in-- he's contagious.
I mean that energy and the mic
drop and the realism of him
is like something you
just want to be around,
because there's not
many people out there
like him, at least that are--
that you see their content every
single day in every single way.
So I would say it's split.
We hire for skill set fit
and a culture addition.
If you went into
Gary's inbox right now,
you would see, I'm sure,
probably 300 people
that are like, I will
work for you for free.
And that might
have just happened
in the last eight hours.
By the time we get
to 8:00 tonight,
there might be
another 150 that just
want to work for us
for free, which is--
that is amazing.
That is, like,
incredible and an honor.
Are those people
the right skill set?
I don't know.
And that's where we have to
start calling through some
of those CVs, if we get.
Now, we have specific
recruiters that
are looking at just media, video
production, account, project
management, and whatnot.
Every now and then, we'll
get sent one of these people,
two of these people, or hey,
the owner of the New York Jets
has a son.
Here you go.
So we have to look through
those incredibly carefully.
Of course, we'll give someone
an at bat at an interview.
That's for sure.
If they are a student,
we'll hopefully
get them into our
internship program,
which is in the summer.
If they are just coming
out of university,
maybe we can get them
in as a resident.
Again, the skills are
super, super important.
Because we move so
fast, it's not charity.
As Gary would say--
he says it a lot--
he's just like, I
mean, what are we doing here?
Like, we're working.
We're here to work.
We are here to hustle and to
be the biggest human agency
in the face of the earth.
But we really need to take our
time and go through those CVs,
and that takes a lot of time.
And then we have to make sure
that we're interviewing really,
really carefully.
Otherwise we could just
get a lot of Gary fanatics
and maybe not a lot
of the specific work
that we need to get done.
But it's always fun to see those
emails come in, a lot of fun.
CHALMERS BROWNE: [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: Hi, [INAUDIBLE],,
I have a question for you.
As VaynerMedia focuses on
building a honey empire or more
of the work environment that has
more heart involved in getting
more comfortable and
connected with your employees
to make them more
productive, and as you know,
Google completely sets
itself in that way as well.
And work cultural is
huge, and diversity
is very important for us.
for the benefit of our
team and employees.
Can you talk about a time,
where you using your approach
towards connecting with your
employees that have made them
more productive,
and so you can say,
yes, this is something
more scalable?
And do you implore other
companies or other agencies,
for that matter, to come
employ that approach as well?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yes.
Let's see.
If I'm tracking correctly,
what I think you're asking
is a little bit of
the training that we
do with our employees that
are basically kind of geared
a little bit towards their
performance and their success.
So the honey in the
empire portion--
maybe looking at this
or looking at what
I was talking about
in the beginning,
which was putting people first.
And if you really, really hone
in and deploy as much empathy
and care and TLC and generosity
and giving to employees,
that the output is--
I mean you just get
tenfold more of the output.
So we do a lot of--
we spend time doing a
lot of small town halls
the size of this room, town
halls, where I will just take--
I will field questions that
come at me about our culture
or about changes or
more transparency.
I'll do that, because
I fundamentally
believe we need
more communication
throughout the agency.
And I should say, I started
at the agency as an SVP
on the client side.
And so I can fully remember for
those 18 months I was there,
I was thinking, gosh, we
need more communication
from leadership.
We need more communication
And now that I'm
in leadership, it's
something that I think
about all the time.
How can we increase
our transparency?
How can we make sure
that we're delivering
on the promise of
the honey empire?
How can we make sure that
we're delivering that growth
and development that
we also promised?
So spending time with people
is super, super important.
I've already said that.
But making sure that I'm
coming in-- it's funny.
So much of what I do, it
comes so naturally to me.
And that's the great thing,
because I'm living my purpose,
to Carrie's question.
I'm able to-- my
purpose is to facilitate
growth and change and people
and companies and teams,
and be a team builder,
and be of service.
And I'm able to do
that every single day.
But I realize not everyone
is able to do that.
So me showing that--
I think it's really
important that everyone
knows that I work for them.
No one-- there's absolutely
no one that works for me.
And I will give
whatever I possibly
can to help someone
over that finish line
or help someone from the 10-yard
line to the 30-yard line.
And that takes a lot of
time and energy and effort,
but I think that's the
wonderful thing about being
in a company,
especially run by Gary,
where he wants to buy
the New York Jets.
And so we function as a
team in many, many ways
and making sure that we're
deploying, to your point,
deploying as much of that
honey in the empire internally.
And hopefully, there's a trickle
down effect in other companies.
AUDIENCE: Can I just
ask a follow-up?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Thank you so much.
AUDIENCE: How do you scale that?
Do you go back afterwards,
and are you able to scale
that dynamic to
say, this actually
works, and it's actually making
our employees more productive?
How do you scale that?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah.
The scaling question is such
a great question for us,
I think at this size,
at the 800 mark,
because as I look
out on the landscape,
it's not anything I'm going
to be able to do alone.
And it's something that
my team can certainly do,
but they're going to need extra
reinforcements very, very soon,
because we can't be in every
place at every single time.
And in order to track back and
see how that employee or that
cohort of people
is-- if there are--
if their needle has moved
since we last trained with them
or we last spent
time with them, it
takes a lot of time and energy.
And it takes away
from something else
that we're doing that might
be extremely pressing.
So it's really leaning
on the culture carriers
that we've built
right now to kind
of be the finger on the pulse
for me when I can't be there,
or for Gary, and making
sure that we can track back,
and there is
something to measure.
But growth is something
that we can feel.
I mean, you can see
it in the water.
You can feel it.
You can certainly feel it when
you're with someone, especially
because we have people
that stay with us
the longevity for a long time.
So you can see how
they've ebbed and flown
throughout their
tenureship at VaynerMedia.
And we really use them,
quite frankly, to help
other people grow
and to make sure
that we are going back and
tying up any loose ends
that we may have missed.
So it's really a human--
it's really human effort.
I mean, thank god for Google and
Google Docs and Google Forms,
because that's what we rely on.
It's human effort,
and at some point,
we're starting to systematize
much more now that we've
past the 700 people mark.
Thanks for the question.
CHALMERS BROWNE: Oh,
we do have a question.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I want to zoom a
little about on a point
the previous questioner asked
around diversity and inclusion
in two dimensions.
So one is, especially on the
creative side of the agency
business, diversity has been--
is, I would argue,
a massive problem
in this part of the industry.
We're then-- LGBT,
people of color
are dramatically
underrepresented
in every creative agency and
every creative department
inside companies.
So I'm wondering if you could
talk about your point of view
on how you acquire that talent.
Do you have a specific
lens for that or not?
And then, something
that I think is
very personal to
a lot of Googlers
is also, how, once
those people come in,
they do feel that sense
of connection, trust,
and empathy so that they
do feel included and want
to build that sense of loyalty?
CLAUDE SILVER: Yeah, thank
you for the question.
That's actually one that
I love digging into,
because as you said, we're
all trying to figure it out.
Mapping the macro to the
micro, mapping a macrocosm
to the microcosm is
much more difficult
than I would have
ever known, as I'm now
looking at it from the
top down and, also,
just being on the floor.
Diversity and inclusivity
is-- and they are
different things, of course.
It's one thing to have a diverse
employee, a NEST, if you will.
But then to deploy inclusivity
in the belonging is, I think--
that's almost more challenging.
So one of the things that
is extremely important to us
is creating a safe space, where
people feel that they can bring
their whole selves to work.
And that means physical safety
and psychological safety,
absolutely, bar none.
We were talking
about this earlier.
It's like literally on
my head every single day.
When people, when new--
let's start with the
candidate experience.
When you are a candidate,
and you walk in,
and if you are a
person of color,
and you aren't seeing any other
people of color, that is--
that cannot feel good.
There's just no way.
If you are female, and you are
being interviewed by males,
there's no way that
feels good either.
So that's just even talking
about like a white female
of privilege.
So making sure that we have as
much diversity in our offices
is really, really fundamentally
the most important thing
that we can do every single day.
And that means hiring for--
like hiring the best person.
Of course, we're
going to hire the best
person that comes our way.
Skill set, culture addition--
I like this idea of making
sure or trying to make sure
that our values with that
candidate and that candidate
are in the same zip code.
It's something I
was just sharing
with the team the other day.
I don't expect your
value and my value
to be completely
apples to apples,
but I would like
them to be similar.
That, I think-- the value
piece of it, I think,
does open up the--
it gives us a little bit more
of an ability to widen our net
or cast a wider net, when we are
looking for those candidates.
Back to creating a
safe space, where
people feel like they can bring
their whole selves to work--
if you are a person
of color, you
want to see more
people of color.
If you are LGBTQ,
you want to know
that we have a PRIDE group.
If you have a learning
disability, or you're dyslexic,
like myself, you
want to know that we
have tools that you can use.
If you have a
physical handicap, you
want to be recognized for that,
not as an other and an outlier,
but that we can embrace
you and take care of that.
So the 3% Conference is going
on right now up the street,
and one of the things I
love about what they've
done there is they've
called attention
to the fact that
diversity is so few
and far between in
creative agencies.
The idea of finding that other,
especially in senior level
creative positions,
is really challenging.
It's really challenging for us.
I'm happy to say, I don't have--
we actually don't have stats
on multicultural diversity,
because people can opt
out of that question.
So what makes me happy is
when I walk across the floor,
and I can see just difference.
And I don't mean
difference with an X.
I mean difference
with a capital D,
because this room is different.
It's something that is just
so incredibly important.
I can't even stress it enough.
It's like I don't
want to even say
it's my favorite
question to answer,
because I don't have the answer.
But it's my favorite thing to
kind of chew on altogether,
and does that mean we need to
lean in on the four Ds more?
I mean, there's pockets in this
city and pockets in Chattanooga
and pockets in schools
that we can lean on
to get different talent.
It's something we certainly
do with our residents
and our internship
to really make
sure we're casting that
wide net and able to mirror
the macrocosm of this world.
And it's something we haven't
we haven't solved for yet.
It is a work in
progress, but something
that is so near and
dear to what I'm doing.
Back to Gary, like,
what are we doing here?
Like, we have to make sure
that we are finding talent
that represents this world.
And one of the things
I'm proud of back at work
is that we have squads.
We used to call them
tribes, in fact,
and we took away that
word, "tribes," because
of the cultural sensitivity.
But we have squads, and
I like to use the word,
"cohorts," quite a bit.
And there's a squad that
is called the Amigos Squad.
And they founded each other.
They found each other.
They founded this group,
first and foremost,
to be able to market
to Latinas and Latinos
and the Hispanic culture.
And now, they've really--
it's an inclusive--
it's an open door group,
and it's an inclusive
group, but it's
one that keeps me very,
very honest about what
we're doing, about
diversity and inclusivity.
And so I'm happy we
have that-- in, still,
a startup, quite frankly.
So thank you for the question,
and I'm open to any ideas
to chomp on for
how we solve this.
Yeah, thank you.
You can tell I'm
passionate about that.
Come on.
CHALMERS BROWNE: So if
you're successful in making
your workplace a place
where people feel included,
feel at home, what's your
approach to work-life balance?
How do you make sure that--
is there a danger of
tipping that too far,
where some people might fail
to build or maintain their life
outside of work?
CLAUDE SILVER: So the
sarcastic me says to you,
is there such a thing
as work-life balance?
I mean, sarcastic
and slightly true.
What I do is--
by no means is it 24/7, but
I'm working quite a bit.
And I'm OK with that,
because I've chosen this job.
I've actually turned
over this idea
of work-life balance
for the moment,
and I look at energy management.
And that's kind of the
term that I look at,
and I try to share a lot
more of with our employees.
We have 80% millennials, so
that right there in itself is--
and we're an agency.
So that is as
cutthroat as it gets.
I mean, you are
beholden to a client,
and that means you've
got to get that
out when you said you were
going to get that out,
unless you're going
to answer the phone
tomorrow with a
client breathing down
your neck, which happens also.
But this idea of
energy management
is something that makes
more sense to me today,
rather than work-life balance,
unfortunately, or fortunately.
Energy management is
really being aware
of how you're feeling,
where your anxiety level is.
Are you at Code Red?
Because if you're
at Code Red, we
need to figure out
how to get to pink
or how to get to an orange.
Setting up little milestones
across your day to,
then, celebrate, take
a break, so you're
going to work for 10 minutes--
I'm sorry-- you're going to
work for two hours on this one
project that you're working
on, this one spreadsheet
or this one deliverable.
You're going to get to a
stopping point, where you know
you can get up, take a breath,
and you can go check Instagram
for 10 minutes.
You can go out and
walk the High Line.
You can go for a cup of coffee.
You can go out to lunch.
Those are things, I think going
back to my project management
roots, I think are
really, really important.
I think if I'm looking at
a Gantt chart of my day
and where my energy
tips and falls
and after lunch and
whatnot, just being super,
super aware of how
I'm feeling inside
and how an employee
is feeling inside
and how that's
manifesting, whether or not
that's manifesting physically,
and maybe someone's grinding
their teeth or
getting really upset,
or how that's just
manifesting inside
with not feeling good
enough about yourself
and feeling
extremely competitive
with that other person.
Or gosh, you heard that
person's getting 10k more,
and you're doing the same job.
So managing one's energy is
super important right now.
Yes, having work-life
balance is like a dream.
I think that if any of us
can go back in time and clock
in and clock out, as
some of our parents dead,
or work that eight-hour day
with a half an hour lunch
break, as some
people do in Europe,
quite frankly, that
is kind of utopic.
And there are places to do that.
I can't tell you
that agency life
is that place right
now, and maybe
as we see more remote working--
you do that really well.
I mean Google does
extremely well.
But agencies are funny,
because for the most part,
you're in roles that you need
to be present on a floor for.
You need to be able to look
across that desk and say, hey,
will you look at my
deck for a second?
There's such a collaborative
yin and yang there.
So work-life balance is
something that I'm aware of,
I wish I had that answer
to, but time management
is where I'm really
trying to get more people
to focus on, and be
aware of just how they're
feeling in any given
moment and when
they can just take a time out.
Timeouts really,
really, really help,
and we all deserve timeouts.
Like, what are we doing here?
CHALMERS BROWNE: Great.
Well, thank you so
much for coming.
CLAUDE SILVER:
Thank you very much.
CHALMERS BROWNE: We're at time.
Let's have a hand for Claude.
CLAUDE SILVER: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]